we could have a Black Swan event in 2024
but I don't think it's going to prevent
the inevitable ball run that's coming I
like to look at history I think it's the
best way to determine how the future is
going to be never 100% but it's a really
good indicator in 2020 obviously we had
the major crash we had Co right at the
same time was the Harvey Bitcoin crashed
50% it went from $88,000 to $4,000 and
yet we still had our bull run a lot of
this money printing is pushing up these
markets the money printing hasn't
stopped how did they bail out those
banks that crashed they printed so much
money secretly to bail out all those
major banks that crashed in November
2022 and that is actually when the Bull
Run started again that's when we bought
them the banks crashed they start
printing money since November 2022 we've
been on the up